deux sens et le chiffre estimé de la
répression quant aux victimes de la
place tienanmen on a parlé de 3000 mais
sans aucune certitude ce soir
l'ambassade de chine à paris protestent
contre l'asile politique accordé à 2
contre révolutionnaires que pékin
désigne comme des criminels recherchés
pour avoir organisé la rébellion à pékin
par mieux un homme femme
condé est notre invité scheibling madame
bonsoir merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation
j'aimerais savoir ce que vous ressentez
quand votre ambassade
l'ambassade de chine vous considère
comme une criminelle tic ou qu'il vaut
mieux que tout le monde me regarde et
vois quelle est la vérité vous avez
choisi de venir à paris
vous avez l'intention de vous installer
ici vous avez reçu la possibilité d'un
asile politique
nous avons demandé à grand français de
nous accorder l'asile politique et de
nous permettre de rester en france mais
ce n'est pas encore chose faite
le gouvernement ne nous a encore donné
aucune réponse je pense que ça va être
très vite maintenant est ce que je peux
vous demander comment vous avez fait
pour quitter l'endroit où vous aviez
quelques secondes la place tiananmen et
vous retrouver à paris est ce qu'on peut
connaître les grands moments de cette
suite
tout d'abord je dois dire que je ne dois
pas je ne peux pas dire de façon précise
comment j'ai fait pour fuir je dois
garder les choses secrètes mais je dois
dire que
j'ai été aidé grandement par beaucoup de
compatriotes chinois dans la fuite
on sait qu'on peut savoir sans révéler
des secrets
par où vous êtes passé parce que vous
avez mis un en devenir de la place
tiananmen jusqu'à paris excusez moi je
vraiment je ne peux pas répondre à cette
question parce que cela touche à la
sécurité de certains amis est-ce que
puisque vous parlez de sécurité vous
vous sentez en ce moment en sécurité oui
oui en france je me sens en sécurité
avec mon mari
êtes vous toujours à l'écouté de ce qui
se passe en ce moment à pékin ou es ce
que vous avez choisi dix ans votre
liberté par rapport à votre cause je
pense que il est nécessaire de faire une
contribution à la cause du peuple
chinois et cette contribution je la
ferai en chine ou à l'extérieur
mais ce que vous êtes toujours à
l'écouté de ce qui se passe est ce que
vous êtes
la militante que l'on a vu sur les
images et est ce que vous vous tenez au
courant de ce qui se passe avec un jeu
sûr c'est tout à fait normal
il sait quelque chose qui ne peut pas
être mis en doute
vous êtes toujours militante vous avez
un rôle déterminant à jouer est ce que
où est-ce que vous avez un petit peu
laisser la politique de côté justement
pour penser à votre propre vie disait-il
en bois
en ce qui me concerne personnellement il
faut que je réfléchisse au fait de
savoir comment m'installer en occident
et comment faire pour aider mes
compatriotes chinois
tout d'abord nous devons moi et mon mari
trouver une façon de subvenir à nos
besoins
ensuite de comprendre mieux la culture
occidentale et ce n'est qu'après cela
que nous pourrons faire un choix choisir
la meilleure façon d'aider nos
compatriotes en chine alors pour le
moment dans votre vie politique il y à
une parenthèse on ne peut pas dire ça
mais pour l'instant depuis deux semaines
par exemple je pense surtout à ma santé
et j'ai besoin d'un peu de temps pour
cela
je pense que arrivera le moment où je
pourrai lutter pour aider mes
compatriotes chinois
une dernière question vous pensez encore
après tout ce que vous avez fait est ce
que vous avez subi qu'il ya une
possibilité d'ouverture en chine
aux siens tiguan qui je pense que ce
problème dépens de ceux désespérance et
de la volonté des la population chinoise
d'après ce que je sais et la population
chinoise espère de tout son coeur que la
politique d'ouverture pourra continuer
mais bien entendu cela dépendra aussi de
l'attitude du gouvernement de pékin la
population chinoise espère que la
politique d'ouverture continuera shining
je vous remercie